[موسيقى]
بالنظر للاساليب الخبيثه اللي ب يتبعوها
الارهابيين بقتلنا
وتفنن بتفجيرات واماكن زرع العبوات صار من
الضروري اتباع اساليب جديده غير هاي
الاساليب التقليديه اساليب نعتمد بها على
نفسنا الطريقه اعتمدتها لكشف سموم هؤلاء
الارهابيين هي طريقه جديده سيطرات ذكيه
سيطرات ذكيه تتوزع بعموم الشوارع بحيث
تغطي معظم مناطق المدينه هاي السيطرات
تتكون من منظومه من اجهزه كشف
متفجرات اجهزه كشف متفجرات راح توزع
بالشوارع بحيث ما راح تصير عندي صبات او
سيطره من هاي الاعتياديه انه اسوي ممر
واحد واخلي السيارات تفوت من هذا الممر
واضيع وقتهم واعرض للخطر
اكثر خلينا هاي
الاجهزه اجهزه معتبره من المؤتمر الاوروبي
للطيران المدني اجهزه حساسيتها عاليه جدا
بحيث ممكن ان تكشف العبوات
اللاصقه والمتفجرات المزروعه داخل الارض
وايضا السيارات المفخخه اجهزه دقتها عاليه
ممكن تكشف المتفجرات جزء المتفجرات من
مليون جزء مليون جزء يعني انا مني اشري
جهاز على الارهابي مو تقوللي والله انا
سني ب بلاتين لا عين انت
الارهابي بما انه هاي الاجهزه ما متوفره
عندي سويت المنظومه بس بدون هاي الاجهزه
ردت بس اعرف الوقت اللي يوصلني به
المعلومه من السياره المفخخه لحد المركز
اللي دا اسيطر عليه واتابع به السيارات
المفخخه نفذنا هذا هذا الشي العملي نفذناه
بمنطقه باب الشرجي سوينا عشر سيطرات ذكيه
وفرضنا انه سياره مفخخه فاتت من يم هاي
السيطره الداتا اللي وصلتني من هاي
السيطره للمركز اللي انا به اقل من نص
ثانيه اقل من نص ثانيه انا شفت السياره
المفخخه واقدر اشوفها اللي موجوده بالكرا
او اليرموك او المنص مثلا هذا وقت قياس
يخليني اقدر اتابعها واراقب واتخذ الاجراء
المناسب
لها هذا المشروع قدمته جهات امنيه عليا
لكن للاسف قابلوه بالرفض وكانت العباره
المشهوره اللي يقولو لي اياها ابني دير
بالك على نفسك مو انا هي هاي الطريقه اللي
اذا اسويها راح ادير بالي على نفسي وادير
بالي على الابرياء وادير بالي على الناس
زين انت ديروا بالكم علينا شكرا
جزيلا
[موسيقى]
ا